hello everybody guess what we have in
this box can't even see you on the other
side
hello hi Jenna what's in the box tell
them what's in the box
I hope it's an Xbox one I didn't
actually even think about that so we are
gonna unbox hopefully what's in here is
the Xbox one AI I'm assuming it is I
don't know I didn't order anything else
are you ready I am okay Google glass
we're gonna put you on Google glass it's
not forgiving when it comes to here
how's this look great
very fashionable sliding it on having
flashbacks glasses booting up got the
fire what is taking so I don't know but
yeah I see the light you see it I do
that sees you look the unboxing begin we
did inside if I look at that it just
burns right away
I hope there's actually an Xbox in here
where it ten come on we can just ran no
wash is where is the nearest
fire extinguisher somebody call 9-1-1
okay oh it's warm
oh yeah you just glitter on fire but it
was oxy some fun yeah oh you should save
this yes I love bubble wrap taste of all
space boss there's my rat poison tastes
like nothing tastes like chemicals and
factories but the Box still quite warm
do you see what I see me Hulu Plus and
Skype or crack deadmau5 $10 on the box
wow that's on the back don't I'll spin
it around ready
which way always wet-looking whoa oh
Oh looking at it with my glass eye
500 gigabytes well this is the official
game console of the NFL so now I just
like my ear down there ya know it's
gotta be good did you see the
commercials with the football players
yeah I suppose once a great commercial
let the big fire
don't fire anymore don't we burn here
with any case you got your xbox on fire
no Xbox unboxing goes wrong Xbox is on
fire FiOS thanks oh come on
what one do all lifts up okay let's do
accessories first I've never touched one
before
mmm Oh wonder what it tastes like
okay oh my god I'm so excited I'm legit
going oh it is nice put it on how I
snapped a reindeer
hello hello hello hello what are you
here nothing what's it taste like
huh it's like a dog turn Jesus no no I'm
not gonna taste this one okay I'm gonna
taste something better instructions
don't one nope oh oh show it show them
the shell in the eye shell in my face
stick it in my face what's the smell
like oh it smells real good yeah smells
like new I shall get in here sorry
Kinect tastes like connect tastes like
nothing
okay hey Candace
we've got power supply II I already
started it up with my smudgy theme yeah
this looks a little dusty I don't think
I'm gonna like this one this is like a
Matt I don't wanna miss the Matt I like
it
I look at that now remind me not to use
that control no how am I gonna play
video games
oh yes I like how it look at this Cena
Xbox one so dirty guys this is real life
moving on okay I don't hit me right to
the boob no it's dying
Oh
remove the box Jen make sure something
else in there yeah the time for that are
you ready
no it's upside down so big he's like the
Starbucks I had this one tastes like
nothing tastes like nothing this tastes
like more fun this tastes like sugar cut
all the lights so this is your tongue
over here girls
hey well your cow was a real gross Pig
girls Pig you turn it on such work on it
check it make some mole then give
me some mole shake that kid is that
haven't working no um how come I not fig
you're not what twerking is yet is the
question
it's like mister first time with glass
yeah do you see warm
nothing actually oh and there we go I
had to push it back further oh oh I see
mess on the stairs
oops the real question is what are we
gonna do for the giveaway I have decided
that I think I want to do a drawing
contest
although the contest is not gonna you
don't have to be an artist it's gonna be
a random but basically I want you guys
to draw me a picture of you maybe me
maybe Jenna with an Xbox one tweet it to
me Facebook it to me YouTube it to me
but use the hashtag IJ Xbox one and
we'll pick a winner in the next week or
two I've never had on Google glass I
feel like a robot
Oh
what's ashtag iDate xbox one do you know
what you have to do for the contest
Jenna let's recap basically put it
everywhere in spam a crap out of me and
I will pick just have to be a picture of
the Xbox one of you and yeah drive wow
I'm gonna go look at stuff Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine any social
network where I happen to be on it and I
can there's hashtags just do it we gotta
get another controller we should create
a game we do we have a game I want dead
rising course got a call of duty ok guys
thanks for watching I love you hope you
enjoyed our Xbox one unboxing um we'll
see you in our next video let me know if
you guys have an Xbox one I'm gonna be
uploading some videos on the upload
studio of gameplay I think you can just
follow me my gamer tag is I 5 tine IJ u
v TI any you're just excited all that
glass on your head see you guys later
I know no more ledges get smudged up get
it off
pig-like oops ok glass stop recording no
that's what why you do it no no no okay
glass my not hurts